[Music]
notes up guys I'm tphd here and this is
the new to the newest 2020 cheesegrater
Mac Pro there's a lot of things that I
could say about this from a couple
months that I've been using it but
mainly they boiled down to three main
things one is extremely well made to the
point of like over-engineered almost -
it's modular finally and three it's
really fast now my typical review video
for a piece of tech that's really good
ends with something like it's really
good you should buy it but with this
even though it's quite good it's more
along the lines of you probably
shouldn't buy it most people will never
need this but I'm really glad they made
it so this of course is the newest
highest end Mac ever made and the max
price that you can pay for it also makes
it the most expensive Mac ever made and
you might remember everyone had a good
time with their headlines with that but
it's more than just that it's the
highest end and most modular tower
computer Apple's made in years and
that's something that people like me
we're waiting very patiently a very long
time for so everything about the design
of the Mac Pro and I mean everything
from the inside out is really well done
but like to the point of over-engineered
like it's it's unnecessary it's the most
over engineered desktop tower I've ever
seen and most of this over engineering
is in the name of aesthetics and noise
so you might remember Apple sort of
showed the world how much they really
care about aesthetics and noise when
they tried to make the last Mac Pro a
tiny cylinder on your desk
cooled entirely by one big fan at the
top but that didn't go so well so while
they are now finally back to making the
modular tower form fact that we were
waiting for that did not stop them from
making possibly the cleanest quietest
desktop computer possible like the
cheese grater design with the holes up
front and a mesh piece behind it it is
weird-looking to the point where it's
like unmistakable you know kind of like
some other Apple products this year but
it's also an airflow design as much as
anything you see the entire Mac Pro when
you take the shell off and look inside
is designed to be passively air-cooled
there isn't much of fans on any of the
internal components there's no liquid
cooling there's just three huge blowers
the front one here back near the rear
and a bunch of heat pipes on everything
so the entire chassis is designed to
pass as much air flow through the system
as possible to cool everything but air
flow is not quiet and even you know fans
like these are not typically quiet by
themselves and if you have all three
fans like this spinning at the same rate
they sort of amplify each other and make
this wine that you'll probably hear now
a lot of pcs do this and this is fine
but Apple decided to make this computer
quieter they'd spin each of the fans at
a slightly different rate so that they
wouldn't all match but even when you do
that you sometimes end up with harmonics
that sort of amplify some of the sounds
and still make it audible so apples fan
controller literally modulates the speed
of each one of these fans and ramps them
up and down so that they never match and
our never study so that you never hear
it and it works another thing you might
notice when the system is open is well
number one you can't open the Mac Pro
unless you unplug everything from the
back including power which is kind of
annoying but I guess not a huge deal
anyway you get it open and you don't see
any cables there is not one single
exposed cable anywhere in the Mac Pro as
you get it from Apple
now there's headers to plug stuff in if
you want but all the first party stuff
just plugs right in with strategically
placed pins so in Apple's ideal world
everything everyone makes is compatible
as npx modules and they just slide in
just like there's keeping the world
clean matte black and easily modular the
only tool you need to do most of the
adjustments inside is a single Phillips
head screwdriver and then to take stuff
out you unlock this big sliding
full-height PCI slot lock that they
didn't have to do but they did and it's
sweet and they labeled everything so if
you don't know exactly what you're doing
they've numbered the parts in the order
that you should remove them to have
everything slide in and out easily so
one is the thumb screws on the side
don't need a screwdriver for those you
can just literally unscrew them to take
off the bracket two is the bridge
between the modules so if you have more
than one this just needs one screw you
just pop it straight off three is the
screws on the other side and you can see
they're still connected to the bracket
with a spring so they're not loose
screws so you can't lose them without
losing the whole bracket and you get
that off
the last step is the very satisfying
lever to pull out of the PCI slot and
then your MPX module is free
now these MPX modules inside also have
no fans in them which means they're
passively air-cooled and they rely very
heavily on the airflow going through
those front three fans and the heat
sinks and that has its pros and cons the
probe being no extra fans means no extra
noise but they also tend to be thicker
than most normal parts because the huge
heat sinks are bigger than just putting
in more fans I mean look at the size of
this GPU versus a typical high-end
graphics card but hey that's what
they've built it around and they've even
labeled the underside of the RAM cover
for instructions on where to seat your
memory depending on how many sticks you
have so you can take best advantage of
this multi-channel memory we're working
with here a lot of this stuff they just
straight-up didn't have to do so they've
clearly paid a lot of attention to fit
and finish so how about performance
because that's why you get a computer
like this at the core and for me it's
been excellent noticeably better for me
even then the maxed out 18 core $12,000
iMac pro that I came from before I was
using this now here are my Mac pros
specs of the machine that I've been
editing on these last two videos you've
been watching were made with and if you
check through those options on Apple
site you will see that I've given Apple
north of 40,000 of my own dollars for a
computer so yeah Christ it should
perform a lot better than any iMac or
any all-in-one ever now again most
people will never need parts like this I
am a Final Cut Pro editor that's my pro
level workflow that's why I need the
speed and power of these pieces and for
that it has been incredible as I've
noted with workflow examples in the past
and I think animators may be high-end
photographers can take advantage of the
power of the Mac Pro but if most people
watching this you know video makers
youtubers even if it's not 4k you don't
even need a base Mac Pro so just know
that we have a couple other Mac pros in
the studio and the one that I'm using
those are my specs but we've tested a
bunch of different ones I won't bore you
with the benchmarks if you want a proper
benchmark filled video with comparisons
I will link - tech tips his video he did
a great job and you should check
out for his Mac Pro review this things
clearly powerful it is definitely not
more than I can ever use though it's not
invincible for all intensive purposes I
have a maxed out Mac Pro aside from the
768 kegs of ram which could be doubled
but essentially this is the best
computer Apple's ever made and you can
still watch it crawl to a halt all you
got to do is shoot an 8k red clip at a
low compression ratio maybe something
like 5 to 1 then import it on to any
large timeline 4k or 8 K suit yourself
set playback to high quality press play
and then observe as the Mac Pro slowly
starts to choke drop frames and become
unusable you can imagine though how like
a MacBook Pro or an iMac or iMac Pro
would have handled that even worse but I
want to talk about that afterburner card
for a minute though because that to me
is really interesting so Apple made a
$2,000 pci decoder card that essentially
just decodes pro res and pro res raw so
photographers don't need it at all
coders anyone making apps developing
don't need it even if you edit in any
other codec other than pro res or pro
res raw you will not benefit at all from
an afterburner card but if you do edit
pro res it will decode those streams and
let you effortlessly playback tons of
high res video streams I think I've said
up to 23 consecutive streams of 4k or 6
8k videos at the same time while it's
basically taking that load off of the
CPU but I don't edit pro res I edit red
code raw so why did I get an afterburner
card well this afterburner card built
around FPGA is reprogrammable meaning
Apple and red can work together to
enable this afterburner to accelerate
red code playback and rumor is this is
something that's already in the works
now I don't have any proof on my end or
any updates that show that integration
has come to fruition yet but the
potential is definitely there for even
bigger video games and that potential
exists for other codecs to Canon raw re
raw whatever other stuff you might be
shooting that's not pro res yet that may
eventually be optimized for the metal
and give you huge performance so maybe
someday in the future I will be able to
play back five to one 8k red code
and it'll just seamlessly butter through
it at high quality so overall to wrap up
the mac pro let me put it this way it's
not just that the mac pro is a really
expensive computer it's more that Apple
chose to make a very very expensive
machine in the Mac Pro does that make
sense like tons and tons of the choices
they've made in this computer would not
be found or even noticed in many other
desktop computers the completely cable
list interior of the system pretty sweet
but totally unnecessary the crazy fan
control the the PCI lock that's really
satisfying the system for the MPX
modules the fact that every button in
this Mac Pro is made of metal instead of
plastic and there's pins for them every
single little thing is carefully
considered and taken to the max so those
other desktop computers are for most
people which is nice but Apple decided
to make the computer that took no
shortcuts and took it to the max with
premium things like build quality and
end performance so I'm happy they did
that because I'm in the very very small
sliver of the demographic where that's
exactly what I'm looking for the
downside is Apple just straight-up
doesn't make a thousand dollar modular
desktop tower like that's not a downside
of the Mac Pro that's a downside of
Apple that's just a product they don't
make there's a ton of products I wish
Apple would make that they just
straight-up don't I wish they would make
like a mirrorless camera because they
already make some of the best smartphone
cameras out there but they just don't
make a camera desktop speakers computer
speakers they don't make that a
multi-device wireless charger they don't
make that either so add that to the list
like 900 to $1200 tower that's modular
Apple just doesn't make that either but
they do make this a silent killer and I
am really happy with it and I'm really
looking forward to it lasting me
hopefully a decade and getting better
over time
that's been it thanks for watching catch
he has the next one peace
also Apple the the $400 wheels they're
great but they they really need locks